alors vous l'avez entendu de quelqu'un
qui voulait devenir pape qui en a pas de
miracle
tous devenir des ambassadeurs et c'est
ensemble qu'on peut se redonner une
économie forte que ce soit mon rien que
ce soit le montréal métropolitain le
québec tout entier suit minute dans mon
cas ça va être un miracle si ce juste
une mention et ed
je commence par ici est-ce qu'on a entre
vous connaissez bonne structure le
vêtement bon les autres voici vous
convertir quoi que ce soit pas sûr bon
match aujourd'hui mais je m'amuse
toujours à dire quand je fais des
conférences et un petit peu partout à
travers le canada est maintenant aussi
en californie qu'ont été inspiré par
l'ingénierie allemand qui compte d'une
voiture allemande sait exactement à quoi
je fais référence la précision suisse
rené vous prenez un trait en suisse mais
10 14 et le medicaid partie même s'ils
avaient mené une canne de sirop d'érable
le design italien chaque peuple un adn
qui lui appartient de parent aura deux
par une symbolique qu'on lui a reconnu
le québécois la québécoise des femmes et
des hommes d'affaires nous c'est la
créativité et la créativité on ce
bénéfice là de pouvoir vers la somme de
l'ingéniérie la précision et le design
sauf qu'il faut se réaliser il faut
aller chercher les marchés il faut aller
changer le monde en ouche et bonne
structure on sait juste donne une humble
petit vocation c'est de changer le monde
de l'habitation échanges et habitation à
travers le monde et à travers le monde
ça commence pas par seulement la
géographie mais ça commence par une
conviction de soins ça commence par
changer les habitudes des gens ou de
voir commentait ce qu'ils consomment un
produit ou un service
il n'avait entreprendre y exporter pour
réussir pourquoi parce que il faut qu'on
sorte de nos petits carrés de sable on
est il vit en arrière des églises disons
le admettons l'heure on s'est toujours
fait dire soit bof un gentil et tais toi
vas pas exploré la frontière ben il est
grand temps qu'on fasse partie de la
parade mondial parce que sinon beau
manquer le bateau et ça dépend que de
nous tous game d'observation qu'elles
sont sur un trou qui est sorti la maison
vous avez tourné à droite ce matin lever
votre main droite mais j'y crois points
de plus que comme ainsi en a qui ont
tourné à gauche levé la main gauche il y
en a qui voient que la main gauche mais
le droitier pas encore fait
il y en a qui sont pas entendus ont
encore on voit que vous n'êtes pas sorti
de chez vous voyez vous commentez ce que
déjà comme un être humain on est pris
programme et on sort la maison tourne à
droite on s'en va starbucks on y prie
programme et l'innovation la créativité
vient quand on est prêt à chambarder
notre propre façon de faire au quotidien
alors tous ceux qui ont tourné à droite
de demain tourner à gauche pour trois
semaines vous allez peut-être découvrir
des choses en allah et vice versa un
autre gain d'observation quels sont ceux
d'entre vous qui se brosser les mains
les paliers même les dalles la main
droite michael est des droits ici
combien de la main gauche il était
démontré que le cerveau et il ya peu ce
plastique orange il s'est ainsi une
forme de de testico logis que si vous
commencez à vous habituer à brosser
vaudaire de l'autre main vous allez
créer 10 contacts dans votre cerveau
semble qu'on ait la journée que vous
allez est à la recherche de l'idée de
cette espèce duré qu alors que vous êtes
dans le désespoir comme ils disent ce
qu'ils écrivent de riders brac
mais ça va venir de nulle part tout cela
parce que vous avoir exercé un muscle
qui est votre cerveau à qui vous avez
déjà pré programmés l'idée de brasser
lead cerveau de l'animal le plus évolué
mais je vous dis je vous challenge com -
maniaque de l'observation au quotidien
de nos habitudes de vie vous allez voir
qu'on pourrait peut-être questionner
c'est vraiment là la scion ceux de
l'être humain
plus on est intelligent - on a gelé
démontrer retour nette hausse à droite
le tour nette hausse à gauche le matin
au dojo pour brasser aidant avec l'autre
main forte à raison vous allez vous
arrachez de quoi ça va être la boussole
miroir mais mise à pors
pourquoi un musée voit poser la question
des gens qui travaillent avec vous peu
importe que ce soit quelqu'un qui balaye
la shop ou quelqu'un qui ouvre son
ordinateur quelqu'un qui installe vos
pneus d'hiver s'est pas déjà fait
quelqu'un qui prépare un cappuccino
arrêter cette personne là alors qu'elle
est en train de rentrer dans la tranche
est posé la question à l'intérieur de
quatre à dix secondes le timing est
bénévole et fait la question la façon
juin et où
pourquoi ce choix zone mais qu'est ce
que vous pensez que 99 points 9 % de la
race animale la plus évoluée sur la
planète terre nonobstant son industrie
sa culture sa religion son pays va
répondre à cette question scientifique
la direction du jeu venu avec on verra
on trouvera seulement moi damned sucden
building communal code de quelqu'un que
tu poses la question
moi j'appelle ça le blender qui était
vrai livre mais c'est mon grain de riz
lui si vous deviez vous passez vos
expériences qu'elle soit passée présente
et future
souvent les gens de notre âge aux i oi
médecins avaient du reste pourquoi nous
avons marché
déjà à l'issue pays le bon cpt palette
là et on vit avec la mauvaise histoire
vous remarqué que nos médias profite de
ton on aime beaucoup raconté les
mauvaises histoires qui est bonne ce
soir on est au carbure pour bones tout
challenge à une petite terre en une
suite technique simon changer mise light
de couleur en sandales à m'éloigner vous
ça s'apprend incapable de vivre avec les
nouveaux une nouvelle façon trop les
enjeux ils sont les mains les mêmes pour
tous que ce soit des québécois et des
canadiens que ce soit les iraniens
peu importe vous allez dans le monde si
on est tous on est toujours comme un
être humain des insultes eu le succès la
voir ainsi beaucoup le mot thibault bout
le surmonte bobos plus grandes mains et
juste nous sommes jusqu'au jour où on
réalise qu'un ado tu as le même petit
bobo ou la même opportunité et ce qui
nous guette présentement c'est que tous
les pays ont les mêmes anges dans un dé
de redéfinition d'économie
l'entrepreneuriat c'est quelque chose
qui est porteur 80% des entreprises on
au mieux ils ont fait ils ont dirigées
par des entrepreneurs petit moyen des
entreprises l'innovation ça c'est un mot
qui est très subjectif à l'innovation
c'est pas part au poignet l'innovation
cette innovation wesh wesh confère une
invasion toi oui oui je on a mis en
boîte la semaine passée l'innovation et
la productivité
on n'est pas des meilleures au canada on
n'est pas des meilleures au québec
si vous regardez tout le data qui sort
présentement oui on se fait dire de
faire plus avec moins
mais malheureusement on répond peut-être
pas à l'appel pour toutes sortes de
considérations la croissance bien c'est
comme dans les bois le coin c'est comme
un athlète des postes pour toi même et
quelqu'un que votre rattraper à chaque
fois si vous regardiez les records et
les cadets et là et quatre ans plus tard
il y en a une autre cour encore plus
vite alors questionnement ce qui fait la
différence
tout commence par l'attitude un moi
j'envoie des entreprises j'en ai vu des
entreprises j'ai eue de faire une vie je
me mettais le management chez bombardier
et tuent aussi que l'attitude ses
comptes pour beaucoup la curiosité on
voit l'école on veut enfin depp et des
confins cégep ont fait l'université ont
fait de maîtrise ont fait un pied de
jeudi puis l'once à l'hadopi bon là
c'est fait j'ai appris que j'avais avant
le mans allait gagner ma vie et on n'ose
pas se remettre en question et à prendre
tous les jours
gros problème de société à moins qu'on
soit pris dans un croc et un moins qu'on
soit pris dans une guerre à moins qu'on
soit pris avec un cancer - qu'on
souhaite pris dans une circonstance hors
de notre contrôle
l'on est obligé d lumineau fusible de
curiosité mais sinon on se laisse coincé
avec le l'ingéniosité je donnais je
demandais justement 300 futurs
ingénieurs l ets dernièrement je dis je
rends dans l'amphithéâtre première
question que je pose est ce que tes
futurs ingénieurs dans la salle oui ça
me réconforte de ce défaut comme sur la
dernière minute fait que je le dis avec
les élèves toute la main j'ai dit
maintenant c'est que des futurs
ingénieux hope alive sont outre gougaud
pige leur ipad ingenious apprentissage
et mieux j'ai mieux 20 kg et un
inquiétant parce que qu'ils vont
redéfinir les normes les standards qui
va comprendre que la société vaut lui
que oui à grâce à des nanotechnologies
peut-être que les performances de la cie
peuvent être aujourd'hui définies
autrement que quand on a commencé à
faire des ponts violente et non pas le
moins la persévérance m'amuse toujours à
diviser le mot si vous voulez percée n'a
besoin d'être persévérant et ça c'est
une chose qu'on a en cinq pots c'est une
chose qu'on nourrit pas notre société
facile de l'arche est facile de
débarquer zappa marché où tu te fais
dire encore ça marchera pour le tempo
parties un accord contredire ça marchera
pas robin c'est le vieux gag on sait
tous qu'un avocat ou un conte un beau
taux de tête altier ce jeu me partie 1 à
fin mai tu rajoutes deux banquiers a su
piloter seul qui propose enfin sauf la
banque nationale monsieur louis vachon
d'un style à lui et pour demain faire
comprendre aux gens aux entreprises ici
que il faut exporter il faut prendre nos
talents notre savoir nos produits
l'exporter ce qui fait la différence
d'une culture c'est quoi une culture ça
commence bien simplement par oublier
lice j'sais pas si vous regardez souvent
que ce soit le globe and mail où que ce
soit le new york times les journaux
d'envergure comme qui dirait de la
praille suppression de l'isf mais les
best sellers lice l'excusé mais existe
le match italie colonnes de fiction
nonfiction bécaud de ben maintenant à la
liste de surf dans le new york temps de
jeu devrait passer les fictions la
confusion le seco a lié cette crue vite
vite vite dans moins d'un siècle
réussissant à faire je réussisse dans
mon mariage je réussis ça m'embêtait ou
en désendetter fit vite 2 - lecointe 8
ça marche pas demain c'est une question
de culture une culture une culture ça
peut être juste authentique et tu peux
pas l'emprunter peut comprendre la
culture d apos de google ou d'apple est
maintenant mon brender père m'a sauvé le
milkshake à ma façon
non il faut que ça vienne de vous même
et de votre équipe
une culture d'entreprise ouverte sur le
monde ici plus qu'ailleurs
qui favorise la curiosité je vous donne
des exemples tantôt qui rejette on a
toujours fait seulement nous avons
effectué on a dit me mo mois s'il ya
quelqu'un de l'extérieur qui se présente
qui ose dire le mot propos pour probo
problème là et tabarouette les autres
fassent de sa perte de travers par les
soixante deux personnes que ce perso ça
me plaise opportunité à l'on comprenne
ce que voulait dire
bon il ya un telle expression tout le
monde va avoir une conversation dans un
brainstorming tout le monde là la
réaction humaine de guam et loti où elle
même mère alors qu'on expose et oui et
ça détend quand tu dis oui mais sert de
ferment quand tu dis oui et ça détend
quelle bonne idée et si on faisait plus
encore et ça ça ne vient que de vous sa
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que le transfert du savoir ne
se fait pas systématiquement des aînés
aux plus jeunes
toutes cultures confondues première fois
big men in humans à cause d'une famille
médias sociaux à cause à l'internet
donc ça veut dire quoi mais ça veut dire
que il ya des nouvelles opportunités qui
s'adresse mais encore une fois il faut
libérer ces expériences fois ball le
coeur et le courage de se renouveler et
de redéfinir peut-être ce qui n'a pas
marché dans le passé dans une nouvelle
consistance dans un nouveau pays dans un
nouveau marché avec des nouvelles
personnes puis je vous jure que les
légendes mon jeu 27 ans badwill mais
tout les jeunes qui se joignent de
présentement dans les entreprises sont
vides sont vite pourquoi parce qu'on les
hait le vis des xbox infections et
multicast youtube une chose était donc
tout est à reconsidérer tout peut être
rebrassées il met en règle à deux
parlaient d'un gradient baisse
appréhendée ingrédients pour mettre dans
le malaxeur des actions quotidien commun
pour compliquer les gens c'est de cette
corsa attaque
comment est ce qu'on va faire
l'innovation comment est-ce qu'on voit
différents arrêtez de vous
voumard fonte d'acier trouver dire c'est
petit plan stratégique qui j'étais chez
bombardier
la première chose notre bon plan
quinquennal l'aqsiq ya une boule de
cristal à ce cher frère un plan de cinq
ans toutes déjà un plan tout aux
instituts on peux-tu d'exécuter le plan
de trois ans est de réajuster en
sandales en tout cas écrire un plan
quinquennal non mais tu sais tu as perdu
deux mois c'est comme quelqu'un le bas
de la piste qui tue moi combien on va
faire deux tours ambac sa piste commence
à tourner des ingrédients religion et
les autres ressources partout dans le
monde
la même chose tant qu'il y aura du monde
apprend du monde selligent des
ressources qui font la différence dans
la guerre donc on a tous les mêmes
ingrédients
par contre on a cet avantage le nous ici
au québec c'est des créatifs des
innovateurs légèrement bombardier nous
sur le soleil céline dion etc
on est les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
sont tous ici au québec une raison on ne
mangeait des cartes depuis 400 ans très
protéinique fait qu'on ait des p'tits
cracks potes
sauf que il faut se servir de ce haut et
le mettre à profit culture ça prend du
temps
je donne des exemples très bonne
structure
ben moi je peux très hiérarchique nommé
on aime une politique en place et à peu
près 8 9 mois j'entrais matin bin
sérieux j'ai commencé les soixante
personnes sont parties ce matin les 15
premières minutes où vous n'avez pas le
droit de travailler
ces motifs de renvoi immédiat
les jeunes aux autres on est beaucoup
plus ouverte sur les cultures parce que
y'a rien comme l'ouverture sur les
cultures pourrait bien aller plus vite
qu'on a on est d'engager quelqu'un du
portugal et de l'espagne
quelqu'un de la serbe le centre de
l'oeil et compris certes il a fallu que
ce soit expliqué quelquefois mais
imaginez si vous avez dans vos
entreprises vous défendez aux gens de
travailler les 15 premières minutes mais
vous les obliger à les apprendre quelque
chose sur un blog trouver un nouveau
choc cote sur leurs softwares
d'enseigner à quelqu'un à côté d'eux un
petit goût de se faire enseigner 15 mois
je laisse à mes enfants c'était toujours
15 minutes de plus par jour que
tottenham en quarts
olic réguler juste un petit 15 minutes
de plus par jour s'il faut voir comment
est-ce que ça va aller vite tantôt alors
ça c'est des petites choses pragmatique
facile qui font partie d'une culture
savait que le mourre internationale au
niveau de la business s'appelait avant
import export un zune même qu on
appelait ça la terminologie changé mais
c'est toujours la même chose c'est pour
bien comprendre les marchés rien de
mieux que d'importer les connaissances
alors c'est plus qu'on a fait nous
aimons ne circule un jour on va vouloir
aller conquérir d'autres mais on a fini
le monde ici pour les pour qu'il nous
conte kate dickie nous nous conte un peu
comment ça se passe ailleurs et 10 m en
hauteur blender fait que ça donnera un
petit goût amer mais conserve le mais le
chèque on va les avoir compris lorsque
romain obstiné qu'on a qu'on implante et
qu'on n'a pas inventé tous les matins à
10 heures pile tout le monde se met en
rogne en 30 secondes pour dire ce qu ils
vont travailler aujourd'hui
oh boy c'est ce qu'on appelle biakan
kobo bing quand le groupe parce que
quand ça toujours tout dit trois fois la
même affaire aujourd'hui il ne commence
c'est sûr que 50% de la rsa c'est
d'amener les gens à participer à
développer la culture pour que ça
devienne il n'y que ça devienne un
réflexe et non pas quelque chose
d'imposé top dans y'a rien de pire
qu'une culture imposé top dance vous que
ça vienne d'en dessous
si comme les marchés émergents c'est
comme des économies émergentes que ça
émergent des gens dans nos entreprises
et c'est ce qui va créer vraiment des
marchés ou des possibilités
l'international du thermos tout vous
remarqué que le mot est bilingue web
internationaux internationale alors ce
qui n'ôte pas anglais ici en sortant du
site où firefox etc sur one one du
wheeling go rosetta stone messmer
investissement fait pas trop lent depuis
quatre ans pourquoi parce qu'on a cette
capacité là nous les québécois ne des
neurones pour les langues
il faut le faire il faut enseigner à nos
enfants de devenir bilingues et
trilingues
c'est la façon d'aller conquérir le
marché j'ai vu des belles entreprises
alors j'avais mon agence de
communication des méchants beaux
produits
les gens responsables et à parler d'eux
- gle commentait ce que tu peux elle y
avoir lieu dit culture comme les indiens
le président par le président directeur
c'est idiot président de palau
vice-président game over finnigan public
donc importance
devoir bien se préparer ce jour
l'international c'est quoi le
l'interrupteur qui fait qu'on a peur ben
justement c'est le mot c'est le mot qui
suit au pied parti s'est passé là-bas on
est élevée nous autres ici dans une
société d'avoir peur c'est bon d'avoir
peur ça fait peur d'avoir peur on a trop
peur mais là c'est le temps d'avoir peur
parce que le reste du monde se
réveillent et le reste du monde a rendu
quand vous dites que les chinois sont en
train de ces points pays émergents le
comme on dit on disait on dit me disait
puis c'est de plus en plus vers une
fourchette part en toupie par tous les
moyens
bell offre faut se faire confiance faut
avancer il faut aller conquérir de
nouveaux marchés